heureux hélène boucher et port royal si
elles paraissent tranquille en journée
aux heures de pointe
elles n'ont pas la même allure les
automobilistes de la vallée de chevreuse
les emprunter le flux important crée
souvent des ralentissements la
circulation de transit est gênante bien
entendu en même temps elle alimente
aussi nos commerces
voilà six voisins n'étaient plus
traverser ou plus et bien peut-être que
nos commerces ne serait pas aussi
n'aurait pas la même vitalité qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui on parle d'un dévoiement fin
d'un contournement parlant de voisins
qui est bien sûr un autre sujet qui
n'est l'un n'exclut pas l'autre
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment qu'on se
concentre sur cette traversée de mozart
je ne peux pas la laisser dans l'état
actuel la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux a donc lancé une
concertation pour réaménager cette zone
objectif harmoniser et apaiser la
circulation de cet axe structurant pour
la ville
une réunion publique a eu lieu jeudi 8
mars pour faire le point sur ce projet
ben c'est une rue qui est fréquenté
maintenant savoir si c'est vraiment un
problème c'est un petit peu ce que l'on
va essayer de comprendre aujourd'hui
pendant cette réunion plusieurs
commerces ont écouté avec attention les
débats sur ce centre ville c'est le cas
du gérant sur cette brasserie implanté
en face de la mairie
pour lui la ville doit investir
raisonnablement dans ce projet moi je
pense qu'on peut très bien réaménager le
centre village tout en restant dans des
choses simples refaire peut-être
les voies refaire peut-être un petit peu
les trottoirs mais pas partir dans des
budgets comme on a entendu deux millions
d'euros je pense que ça fait beaucoup
est ce que c'est vraiment nécessaire et
est ce que vraiment ça en a besoin
aujourd'hui jean suppose sur les
différentes propositions sont
consultables en mairie le projet prévoit
de diminuer la part de trafic de transit
réduire les vitesses tout en maintenant
l'activité commerciale du centre ville
un chantier que la mère espère voir
débuter en 2020 malgré les
revendications du groupe d'opposition
divers droite tous rassemblés pour
voisin qui demande notamment de ne pas
créer de nouvelles rues pour éviter la
concentration automobile dans la ville